today is National handbag day so who
better to celebrate with and Max fun
luxury joining us to talk all things
designer we have Max Pawn owner Michael
Mack it's always so great to see you one
because I love seeing you too because
you always bring the good stuff we
always come with it and I'm seeing a lot
of color is that the trend right now
what are we looking at well you know
bright colors are big and of course you
picked out the most popular color these
greens onto it green the yellows yeah
but uh fall colors popping people are
wearing mixing it with a lot of
different black so you can wear black
with basically anything here it's just
it adds that pop of color to any look
and in addition to kind of the smaller
bags here I am just drawn to this as
well what is this so this is a limited
edition
um Virgil ablo who passed away recently
this is one of his last collabs wow that
he did and you can see it almost has
like a prism finish like 3D
gosh just to touch it is amazing okay
you guys have so many different things
to look through but let's talk about it
when you come into the shop you're
looking for a bag what kinds of things
should we keep an eye out for I know
that you guys authenticate everything
run me through that process so you hit
it on the head the first thing you look
for is authenticity and how do we
authenticate you know it could be just
Michael Max says this is real and that's
real but really we use a third-party
authenticator called entropy it takes a
microscopic photo all the way to the
microfibers of the bag send it to a
database artificial intelligence it
gives us a yes or no and we create this
card that goes with every bag we off we
authenticate everything and we guarantee
it authentic or we'll give you two times
your money back that technology alone to
me is so incredible but I feel like it
just kind of sets you guys apart and
takes you to the next level this is all
true stuff very authentic and just so
beautiful on top of it and you said the
store is really full right now what else
you guys have there in addition to
handbags well you know we're beefing up
we're opening new stores so we have to
buy a lot of inventory so what better
place to store than on our sales floor
so lots of great items you know we have
belts wallets sunglasses bags clutches
and of course we have even little
Stadium bags you know everyone has to
have their Stadium Bag I don't know if
you've gone to a Raiders game got sent
back yes you got plenty of times you
gotta have the small one but I'm sure
you have the stylish ones instead of
just the clear boring ones you make it
fun because that's the worst when you go
to a game but you know even if you can't
fit your phone in it it's worth it to
have something cute exactly okay and you
have diamonds too right that's my
favorite thing okay and anytime that
you're here you always pick out a purse
to go with my outfit so what are we
thinking today which one what are you
loving right now well I'm thinking that
you're you're ready to head on travel
yes travel and style this is a Gucci bag
oh my gosh I could just stay here all
day Michael's always so great to see you
congratulations on expanding you know we
always have a national holiday we can
talk about so be sure to go stop by Max
Pond luxury you can get all the good
stuff all right look away I'll see you
later